pick on someone smaller exactly the best
way to make anyone
everyone and welcome to our guide to
need for speed payback
brought to you by EA I'm Dan and I am
joined by Yanni now on this episode we
are going to tackle the huge open world
that is fortune Valley there are loads
of activities to do outside of the
Street leagues outside of the story of
cinematic missions and so we're gonna
take a look at just some of the
activities that you can get up to on the
street you're at a roll let's do it so
every icon you see here relates to
either an event that you can enter or
some of these sub activities that you
can do some of the key locations you can
travel to the collectibles let's take a
look at just some of the stuff you can
get up to on the street so what we found
there roaming racer roaming racer so
these are cars that drive around the
world of their own accord and if you
bump into them you can initiate
spontaneous races with these people the
trip of the roaming races is that
they're their concert in the move as
well so the best thing you can do is set
waypoints on in their vicinity that's
them
let's do this baby one way ahead 400
points to win this isn't too much of an
off road right no really first you get
100 points you're currently on six
points but you've got a good six miles
to clock at that school oh wow if they
dirty yeah I've seen some scarier
roaming racers on the track some people
are like level 290 which is nowhere near
at the moment you won bail will return
there's two more levels which means
every time you tackle those running
racers they're gonna be in better cars
and just for doing that you've also
unlocked a customization for the grill
on your car in this speedrun here now as
well we've gone straight out of that
roaming racer into another one of the
side activities it's now
Yanni's goal to maintain a high average
speed it seems here that you need to do
90 I think your current average is 139
miles now which is still only a one-star
victory but it means that as you
progress unless your cars get better
there's always a reason to go back and
tackle those speed runs again tackle
those jumps again tackle those speed
traps again and
better impaired schools so the speed
traps can pretty much appear anywhere on
the map we're in the middle of an
airfield right now and you're about to
see a speed trap in the middle of that
and we're trying to hear at least 120 I
think you're well in excess of that you
just clocked 155 got two stars you've
got a series of jumps either side either
there or this one two stars hundred and
thirty nine yards they go that's it
so you've literally come out of that
speed trap bomb straight on and got
another one so that's that's two
activities achieved literally directly
after each other so one of the things
you've got to do when you're not
engaging in races you've got to explore
any little side street you see it's
pretty like it's um it's gonna be
stashed away
ahaha what do we see here roulette chip
here we go
look at the money we pick for chips big
though so there are as we've just found
out one of a hundred and it's the
notification has just popped up we've
got a billboard nearby as well and now
you think in this mildly souped-up
Marquand golf that I've got a chance I
should give it a bit of a run up and
then hit night by the night for a supper
sport
yes thank you very much when I have 100k
smash billboard sport rep and Bank so
there you have it just a flavor of the
huge array of activities on offer to you
in Need for Speed payback's massive open
world
Yani you were getting a few one stars
few two stars there and guessing the
hunger to nail those three star scores
is already Saudi public number I like to
achieve everything in the game the more
you practice the more you achieve the
more fun you have absolutely and now in
the next video we're going to be
exploring paybacks different car classes
and how that affects your race style
join us then see
[Music]